people always say well woke miss
political correctness it's a storm in a
teacup on campus actually it has very
far-reaching effects when it percolates
down into outside the campus hello and
welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
Foster i'm constantine kissin and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest this week is a
professor of politics at Birkbeck
College at the University of London and
the author of white shift which is as he
tells me now out in paperback Eric
Kaufman welcome back to trigonometry
delighted to be here again first in the
new year apparently yes you are the
first thing to view were recording since
the new year and since not the first
since the election but the election was
very recently and before we dive into
that and some of the thing one of the
reasons we wanted to have you back is
some of the stuff you've been talking
about for quite a while was predictive
in terms of what's happened recently and
what may happen in the future but just
before we get into that remind everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been your journey through life
yeah so I'm a professor of politics at
Birkbeck University of London
I've studied each questions of
nationalism particularly majority ethnic
groups so when we talk about white
majorities that's the kind of thing that
I've been studying for over 20 years and
I think that sort of a politics has
become increasingly important and
particularly with the post-2014 populist
wave so a lot of the elections since
2014 I think have been characterized by
the rise of this new form of populism
and also by polarization so both of
these phenomena populism and
polarization are important the other
thing I would say is I've also done a
lot of work on the history of the
cultural Left going back into the 19th
century and I think that's another part
of this story which is really important
which is how the cultural Left has
changed over time and become now a
dominant force in the culture and what
that's doing to our politics I'm kind of
interested in the intersection of the if
you like the cultural left and this new
majority group nationalism and how these
two things are interacting
the polarization that comes from that
absolutely yeah and so they feed off
each other right so the populism is in
some ways caused by the success of the
cultural left which then in turn reacts
to the success of populism and you get
this you know polarization in the
culture and also increasingly in in
electoral politics
sounds like a good justification for
Nazism anyway anyway but so we mentioned
about the election so let's start there
what do you think happened and why is it
that the left still can't admit that
they lost well exactly so I think this
election is a perfect example in Britain
of what I'm talking about which is the
rise of cultural conflicts to prominence
instead of the old left versus right
economic I'm not saying that's gone but
that issue of redistribution versus free
markets which was so big with Reagan and
Thatcher is increasingly being
superseded by questions around identity
immigration brexit and so forth and we
saw in this election that the
Conservative Party was able to
consolidate that sort of brexit vote
around itself including a lot of brexit
voters who were to the left economically
historically come from labour voting
families they happen to live in the kind
of constituencies you need to win in
order to swing because most of the
constituencies in England and Wales are
leave voting constituencies so in a way
the rise of this cultural politics the
way the Conservatives were able to speak
to that brexit voting group allowed them
to win this election since then of
course as you mentioned yeah what has
been the left reaction has it been
reflective right and because in a way
the the proper reaction would be to say
given the electoral map given the seats
the fact most seats are leave voting
seats the fact that you know we can pile
up votes in the college towns and in
London and we're never gonna win an
election so the reality is we should be
focusing on winning back those seats in
the north and Midlands which means we
have to at least make some pitch to the
culturally conservative left-wing voter
that hasn't happened instead what
there's been is this kind of doubling
down and there's belief that somehow
well now the brexit is gone that issues
out out of the way we can get back to
our same old message and then
we'll get these people back because yeah
okay brexit was an anomaly
it was a brexit election with that out
of the way you heard John McDonnell
after the election that was his sort of
post-mortem my viewers that's
wrongheaded that that what's happened is
much deeper than this that that what has
occurred I mean if we take a step back
and we go to the brexit phone what you
could see is that a lot of longtime
labor voters who voted brexit were a
specific kind of voter they didn't tend
to vote very often they had low interest
in politics very often are less educated
that is a key group of voters the kind
of less educated less participatory
labor voter for the brexit vote so a lot
of them voted leave what's happened I
think in the last in 2017 Corbett's was
still able to do to do reasonably well
because these low information voters had
not yet twigged to make the association
between labor and kind of anti brexit
and and kind of Pro immigration and some
of these things which they reflexively
oppose but now by 2019
the penny had dropped and they came to
view them as oh they're trying to stop
ranks it and the other guys actually
want to get brexit done so I think that
it takes longer for the low information
voters to kind of to make this equation
we're in the kind of political sphere we
we we're on Twitter whatever so we think
how could anybody not make the
association between labor and being sort
of anti brexit however it does take
longer for low information voters and
the same thing happened in the US
Obama's presidency actually was an
important symbol for a certain kind of
low information white voter often you
know in many cases a racist voter who
didn't realize where the Democrats were
on these issues and now I'm not saying
that's I don't endorse that by any means
but for some voters the cues the kind of
ordinary party cues which are
sophisticated etc will go over their
heads and I think what's happened now is
these voters have turned and it's gonna
be very hard for them to go back into
the labor column unless labor makes an
offer like the Danish Social Democrats
which is more conservative on on the
issues these voters care about
culturally which are which would be
brexit which would be immigrant
in particular identity issues national
identity patriotism so these sorts of
questions perhaps security but those
sorts of questions I think labor is very
uncomfortable with I think I'd David
good heart and I know Matt Goodwin's
mentioned this has mentioned that you
know a lot of Social Democratic parties
or left parties are very uncomfortable
moving to the right on culture where is
a lot of conservative parties are more
comfortable moving left on economics
that's more true especially if you look
at Johnson moved left in terms of the
minimum wage and spending on the NHS and
a number of these issues he a deficit
etc he's really broken with Thatcherite
orthodoxy relatively easily and that's
been accepted it's been a little bit
harder going in the United States Trump
has done some of that on Social Security
in the deficit he hasn't gone the full
distance in terms of infrastructure
spending in minimum wage but he's got
part of the way that sort of gets to
that point that it's easier for the
right to move left on economics than the
left to move right on culture which was
good hearts point and and that kind of I
think also speaks to these questions of
woke nests and political correctness
which are caging in the left preventing
it perhaps from moving to an area where
you know in terms of their own
self-interest they probably do need to
move which is in a more to a more
conservative position on culture it's
sorry I was just gonna say because that
is a point very good hard raced it and
that Goodwin raised it saying you know
that it's very difficult for the left as
they are now to move to a more socially
conservative point of view and I just
would like to know why do you think that
is well it's mainly because the sort of
activist cadres are influenced by the
intellectual currents in the
universities where there's been
something called the cultural turn of
the left since the 60s which is away
from class and away from this idea of
the working-class and historical
materialism in these sort of Marxist
ideas towards the new identity politics
race gender more recently sexuality that
these kinds of tropes have become more
important so those issues are their
sacred issues now for the intellectuals
and who are influential at the upper
layers and amongst activists right so
that then if that's what's motivating
these people to work
for the party to come into the party the
last you know they won't die on this
hill before they kind of give up those
those aims and so that simply locks the
party in and prevents it from
essentially backing off on those issues
so it's really that that's us this is an
example of where people always say well
woke this political correctness it's a
storm in a teacup on campus actually it
has very far-reaching effects when it
percolates down into outside the campus
so one of the examples is left-wing
parties if it constrains their ability
right to to move rationally in a in a
political marketing space towards where
the market is then you've got a problem
Ryan's and I think that it's very hard
for parties to overcome the Scandinavian
Left has been able to do it better
partly because I think because those are
smaller societies where the polarization
is less extreme and I think there's more
of a sense that well actually we have to
listen to our base a little bit more and
so on but I thought but I think in in
anglo-american societies there is much
more of a disconnect between the kind of
elite metropolitan group on the Left who
are influenced by these intellectual
currents than you left etc and what the
voters want we are really saying is
they've been captured by this activist
yeah and and it's not just captured by
activists who have an agenda but it's
also what's really important about the
local news is that the ability to
intimidate right so it's not just that a
whole bunch of people believe these
ideas it's also that they can enforce a
code a taboo that you know if you decide
to challenge that - I mean Len McCluskey
did this a little bit talking about
immigration just prior to the election
the union leader here and you know that
is something that you're gonna get
hauled over the coals for attacked as a
racist for well or do you want to take
that risk it's very unpleasant so again
this ability to wield taboos is a kind
of force multiplier for the new left and
so it's not just the power of their
ideas but it's the pot it's the power
they hold over reputations and over the
over public morality
it allows them to expand their power but
what that does is it sort of locks in
the the left and so we I think Matt
Goodwin tweeted a whole series of
countries in Western Europe where the
the left the main left-wing party has
had its worst result ever you know since
the thirties I mean the same results
that we see for labor occurring in a
whole range of European countries and
that's again as a result of this I think
anyway inability to move right if you
like on culture I think that the
left-wing agenda economically is
reasonably popular that's not that's not
the problem it's more the the fact that
they are locked in by these taboos or by
the new left belief in some of these new
left Shibboleth so they're just unable
to adapt and and where that goes will be
very interesting hello guys I hope
you're enjoying the episode now the more
eagle-eyed of you will have noticed that
Constantine isn't here and the reason
for that is because he's gone bareback
with Vladimir Putin horse riding we're
delighted to announce we've got a new
sponsor and it is cutie and cutie is a
social media platform that encourages
intelligent debate now what we're gonna
do is we're gonna have a link on this
video and in our pinned comment and
after this episode you'll be able to
click on the link and it would to write
you straight to the cutie and you will
be able to discuss about this week's
episode now the reason cutie is so good
is because it ensures that your comment
will not be drowned under a sea of
others you'll be able to search comments
by topic and it allows and promotes
intelligent discussion so you'll be able
to go on and really get into the meat
and bones of the episode you'll be able
to listen to other people and who knows
you might be able to change your mind
which will be a first because nobody has
ever changed their minds on a social
media platform so go in check it out see
what you think and also at the end of it
cutie will be able to create a report
and you'll be able to see what the
trigonometry audience thinks whether
they think Trump will get reelected who
will be the Democratic candidate
two-twenty and why is it that labor keep
making the same [ __ ] mistake again
and again go to cutie guys see what you
think
join the conversation before we dive
into that political correctness which is
an era that you've caught researching I
wanted to pick up a couple of things
like I mean in terms of moving the right
moving left on economics well I looked
at my the news websites this morning and
there's something that there's a
government minister talking about how
some kind of rail company will be
nationalized immediately and I literally
thought I woke it up and every for a
very novel and someone slept on a
butterfly you know what I mean like it
seems a very smooth process for for the
right to move left on economics that
seems to they don't seem to have a
problem losing their base because their
base is now the socially conservative
largely working-class people you might
say yeah and I think the difference is
that there isn't you know if for the
right to move left on economics doesn't
break a taboo as much you know it
doesn't mean you're going to be attacked
as a morally deficient a monster that
makes a difference right you're not
going to be shamed and it's this whole
sort of shaming enforcement of policing
of virtue policing of language only
sorts of things which are identified
with that left side of the ledger which
which don't exist as much on the right
now of course there are entrenched
interest so that in the United States
for example in the Congress there are
still a lot of members who who grew up
on Reagan and Ayn Rand and believed in
free Mya so so they're it's harder to
you know for example to raise taxes or
to to to redistribute would be a harder
row to hoe I think there because of the
that you know these these sort of
libertarian ideas probably are more
entrenched but I do think they moving
away from that doesn't quite carry the
same sting the same stigma I guess then
someone on the Left moving right on
culture would and before Francis takes
us into the political correct I just
wanted to clarify because it's it's a
very triggering term for some people
when you talk about low information
voters of course you are not using that
in a derogatory sense and by this point
all the people who have been offended by
it we can just talk to talk to the rest
of them but
you know you're not saying there's a bad
people well no you're saying is these
are people who are politically not very
active they may not read the times every
single day and whatever yes doesn't
necessarily mean their opinions are any
less no no their opinions are equally
valid but maybe they pay less attention
to the warp and weft politics they're
not in the Westminster bubble then you
know so maybe I mean in a way that's a
good thing
it is correlated with not having a
degree for example but it's not a
hard-and-fast so there are people with
degrees who are not interested in
politics and vice versa and I think
what's occurred you know if we there's a
long US political science literature on
this that you know essentially if you
looked in the 1970s and 80s at the
states and you categorize them by how
liberal or conservative their
electorates were on one axis and then
whether they voted Democrat or
Republican on the other there was no
relationship at all right so most really
what most people were conservative and
they were Democrat but bipartisanship
there just wasn't this link between
ideology and party which we think of so
automatically because we again we think
in these ideological terms a lot of
voters don't the party is one thing it's
something you get from maybe from your
parents or friends and then the ideology
is just an inchoate bunch of views that
you've kind of come to what's occurred
in the u.s. of course is now if you take
state ideology and partisanship it's
like a straight line you know point nine
correlation so it just dramatically
changed and that's why you get this
polarization so those are the processes
I think we're occurring here too where
the kind of more you know less
participatory voter who didn't
necessarily understand which ideology
went with which party that equation is
starting to be made more and more
particularly on these kind of cultural
issues and as that happens actually
locks in a sort of more deeply rooted
partisanship amongst couldn't say
conservative voters or if you're liberal
minded moving towards the you know
towards the left although the liberal
minded voters because they tend of
higher education are more likely to have
already made them move right so to be
able to identify which party represents
which ideology basic stuff but that
alignment of ideology and
voting is very important explaining some
of the patterns we see particularly the
polarization and it's very interesting
and you're talking about polarization
and one of the factors that is really
contributed to polarization is political
correctness now I suppose a
counter-argument to that would be Erik
what's wrong with political correct
doesn't it mean that I just not allowed
anymore to hold racial epithets a bit of
people outside in my white van you know
political correctness well I think as
you and I probably know the devil is
always in the details that if political
correctness means don't call a black
person the n-word you know we're all for
political correctness it's when you
define racism in an expansive way right
so it's it's when you say if you're in
class reading from a 19th century text
where someone used the n-word that you
are essentially the same thing as using
the n-word yourself I mean that that's
kind of ridiculousness of expanding or
when you say if you're against
affirmative action you are as bad as
someone in the Jim Crow so so that's
really I think what we mean by political
correctness is expanding the overreach
is what yeah overreach sort of this this
elasticity and bending of what Orwell
said you know two plus two equals five
and not only will you agree to that but
you will be made to believe it I mean
this is sensual when the meaning of
words becomes political and not what
ordinary people how they categorize
things in a social scientific way which
is based on you know the scientific
method which is to do with measurement
and clusters of differences and that's
how we categorize the world Athens
instead is about no this is a racism is
what I say it is but but what this then
means is the expansion of concepts like
harm and racism and sexism and so on a
means that more and more more and more
people aren't you know we could talk
about British politics for example if
you say that the this whole issue about
the Windrush which was about essentially
administrative error and not you know
mess ups at the Home Office but which
was not racially motivated but which
subsequently people like Clive Lewis and
after her
you know these commentators are very
quick to try and identify that as racism
right so this broad brush approach but
what that does actually is it there's
been about four experiments which show
quite clearly and there's you know I've
actually done one of these studies
myself whereas if you take the same
statement and you call it racist you
will get a blow back in from in public
opinion people react negatively to that
particularly conservative type voters we
know from the public opinion research
for example that you know most white
Trump voters are actually fairly warm
towards African Americans and Hispanics
you know it's it's not that they are
particularly they're not cool towards
those groups they're just not as cool
towards white people as white liberals
are fascinating because this is a reason
we love talking to you and Matt and and
other people because you've actually
done work on this you're not just
talking about it on Twitter you've
actually done the research and what
you're really saying is that if you
expand these concepts of harm done by
words right what that creates is
pushback from people who go [ __ ] you I'm
not racist you know any and that then
creates the polarization that we see
which then leads to election results
that we see is that is that way yes yeah
so so you get to things like in the
Trump case hostility to political
correctness was second I mean in the
work I've done on both the primary
Republican primary vote but also that
switchers in the general election then
this hostility to political correctness
next to views next to wanting
immigration controlled and reduced that
seemed to be the second most important
factor let's just pause them yeah that's
incredible
is massive that is incredible people
care about restriction of speech right
and being mislabeled
as something they're not almost as much
enough to that for that to be the
primary issue in their choice for the
leader of the free world as they say
that is quite an incredible thing yeah
it is an incredible thing and it has you
know and there's been a number of
experiments where I think in one case
they they were talking about taking down
Confederate statues or something and
they said that this this is a bad policy
and then the next time time they said
well this is the this we don't want this
policy because it's racist or maybe the
wall was that was the example and in all
these cases you could see that when they
threw the term racist in there there was
a lot more resistance to to the
statement right so and so a number of
these experiments have kind of found
that there's this direct reaction
amongst a chunk of voters another paper
that I'm involved in now with some other
people they've done most of them yeah
don't give him any was only about this
it was a sort of an example where you
know kirsten gillibrand the kind of very
woke us democratic candidate and we had
the statement saying you know if my kids
wore a hoodie and and was black he would
be you know arrested and it's only in
fact my kid has white skin that he so we
had this sort of paragraph in there and
you can see the support for Gillibrand
amongst people who read that paragraph
simply drops Andrew you know quite
dramatically compared to when they
didn't have that same wording and again
it's an example of his reactivity that
this sort of expanded use of the term
racism invokes in people now in the in
the election here again I don't have any
I'm not gonna I always want to see the
data and the research so I can't say
this for sure but there is a certainly a
perception that there was among some
voters this idea that the Labour Party
in some ways look down on them and
thought of them as being a bit racist
for voting for brexit again we need to
see the data I don't want to jump ahead
of the data but if that was the case
that would be another example of this
phenomenon where there is this blowback
effect from political correctness and of
course what happens is if if populist
then are successful you won't you get a
sort of reaction on the other side which
is like oh my god these people are Trump
is so awful and and starring in a duck
you know I'm gonna be more opposed to
these people and vilify this government
or Trump or Johnson or somebody as a
monster and so you actually get this
back and forth so in the last European
elections
20-19 European elections you could see
both the populist right parties
increasing but also some of the kind of
more cultural left doing well the green
now of course green also involves
obviously the environment which is a
somewhat separate question but there is
also a kind of I think a reaction to the
rise of the populist right on the
cultural left as well in the college
towns and some of the larger cities that
have larger professional populations so
you're kind of seeing this dialectic
going on which is sort of polarizing but
another example of particularly this
question of political correctness
impacting on populism really has to do
with the question of immigration right
so if if restricting immigration is
defined as racism there or or if for
example deporting people who are in the
country illegally is defined as racism
then all of a sudden that that is is a
massive shift so a voter you know a
party cannot go like the Democratic
Party could not talk about enforcing the
border anymore if that is now seen as a
racist thing what does that do well it
it Bolton's you know it allows market
share for somebody who is going to talk
about this problem so in the case of
Sweden for example the only that the two
main parties were kind of agreed that
we're not going to talk about reducing
immigration levels because that would be
kind of racist and this is an example of
the power of politically correct norms
to constrain the discourse what we call
the of Urton window of acceptable debate
and to take certain questions off the
table of democratic contestation well
what that does is it's I think I may
have used this metaphor last time of the
Soviet department store where it's one
pair of pants we're only gonna sell this
style and that's it okay well then
people want actually a range of other
things they want jeans etc and so the
black market will pop up to provide what
the mainstream won't provide and that's
exactly what the Sweden Democrats were
they were kind of a black market party
they provided the opposition to
immigration and and lo and behold they
signed a shot up to 25% I don't know
where they're at now they're very high
again but that's an example of how this
political correctness the downstream
effect of it was to create a marketplace
for the populace right by shutting out
the main street parties because they
couldn't cross the red lines right or or
another example would be Tommy Robinson
in the English Defence League you know
if you know the local authorities had
dealt with the Asian grooming scandal as
normal local authorities should it would
never have expanded into this big issue
but because of political correctness
because it was it happened to be Asians
which is you know most Asians were nice
not involved and we're talking about a
very small number of people here but the
fact that they happen to be Muslim
Asians was something that made this very
difficult to address by these local
authorities which then meant the problem
kind of metastasized out of control and
then opened up space for Robinson and
others to exploit right so again if you
are gonna explain the rise of Tommy
Robinson it's very hard to do that I
believe without political correctness
political correctness is really oxygen
to that kind of a figure so if we're
going to we can't just think of
political correctness as something that
happens on campus and restricts somebody
from speaking on the campus it has these
very important kind of downstream
effects which are leading to populism
and polarization and I think that's kind
of one of the key messages of my book
too is to say well we have to look at
how these things interact in the round
yeah it's a great book and you've talked
about a lot of the stuff that since
happened right why we're delighted to
have you on so I just want to make it
clear and I'm a little bit slower than
everybody else in the room so yeah I
just want to so calling someone racist
doesn't persuade you to vote for this
something like that yeah yeah okay
lovely to nala and so what you're
essentially saying the issues of freedom
of speech and political correctness are
linked and what you have with political
correctness wants it sort of grows out
of control is it affects people's
ability to express themselves which
doesn't it sort of give credence and
embolden unpleasant views because it
gives them a certain glamour that they
never had before yeah absolutely I think
because once you kind of debase the
currency of racism then somebody who
genuinely is a racist can say well you
know their call
you racist for wearing a Chinese prom
dress and they're calling me racist well
hey we're the same and and so it kind of
makes it impossible to make whatever
actually very important distinctions
right because there really are nasty
racists out there that we need to be
able to call out and even within an
individual like Donald Trump some of the
things he says really are are you know
something like insinuating that Mexicans
are rapists is an awful racist thing to
say whereas talking about a wall is not
and yet those two things are completely
meshed together in this this narrative
of you know like the wall is racist and
deporting people is right well no
actually it isn't but saying Mexicans
are racist is we have to be able to kind
of make those fine distinctions and that
becomes impossible when this charge is
being lobbied being lobbed time and time
again so just yeah and yeah so the free
speech question of course is you know
that is a sort of separate arm so all of
these kind of effects one is that
polarization and is a result of
political correctness but another effect
of course is you know the effect on free
speech say in universities or in comedy
as you guys are probably familiar with
and and how do you tackle this for this
issue of free speech on campus because
it seems to have been so going back to
when we were at university which was the
turn of the century which makes us sound
incredibly old I don't remember that
being as much of an issue but it seems
to in your own words metastasizing it's
got worse how do we tackle that so we
have balance so we have two sides of
people discussing debating well I mean I
actually and I you know people have
different views on this I think this is
not as new as people think that in the I
when I was at the universities kind of
shows my age this is kind of in they
nine early 90s late 80s period net a lot
of the same kind of things were going on
perhaps at a smaller scale that wasn't
social media but there was speech codes
there was political correctness there
was a lot of these it's just just I
think what's happening now is to some
degree to some degree there is more of a
challenge to these things and that's
bringing out more of a reaction to some
degree the social media I think there
was some good work by Zach Goldberg
in the United States who shows that the
rise of online new services like
BuzzFeed and Vox but also but also with
social media there it doesn't explain
the rise of the populist right but it
does a pretty good job in terms of the
what the grade are woken into use
Matthew Iglesias is term this kind of
sudden emergence of this very radical
cultural left sensibility now how do you
address that on campus right okay so the
question is you have the heterodox
Academy you have people in you know on
the internet that Jordan Peterson's of
this world and they are creating a
counterculture which i think is very
important but ultimately i don't think
that's going to be able to penetrate
these institutions because the
institutions are actually captured no
speaking in terms of the universities
which i know well you know most people
are perfectly nice and rational and
normal you have a small group of very
committed very highly networked radical
authoritarian leftists and they are very
important because they also know how to
exploit the procedures and the policies
of the university to to their advantage
to say shut down speakers to get people
fired to you know and I've locked horns
with these people on a number a number
of occasions I've had sort of I think
I'm on my third internal investigation
what what they try and do is to you hit
you with a trumped-up charge let's say
racism or sexism and in the policy it
says you know we don't you know we want
an environment that is safe for people
and no one's going to be discriminated
and against on the basis of race and sex
and they say look you know he whatever
he see maybe he read out from it from a
paragraph that had the n-word on it and
therefore he is in the same category as
the racist that you mentioned in your
policies and therefore he must be
removed from the university or or or
maybe that there's a speaker who
shouldn't be allowed in right so it's
that twisting of the meaning of words
increasingly my view is that the only
way to tackle this is going to be to
actually have more government regulation
of these sectors in terms of specifying
in very very fine detail what
the meaning of words is what what the
meaning of racism is so if someone
actually does call some of the n-word in
in class then yes that is that is an
offense which you know and there's no
way free speech trumps that but on the
other hand if somebody is you know in a
nuanced way reading a passage or if they
are you know expressing a view on brexit
or whatever in class then that cannot be
interpreted and stretched into meaning
they violated college policy so this is
going to require very kind of targeted
forensic policies from governments
actually I think in order to keep what
this is about is it is not about you
know and of course I know some liberals
who would say it's real liberals who
would say well you know institutions
have to have autonomy isn't it a liberal
when we get the government involved the
problem with that reasoning is that if
you have a kind of a vigilante or a kind
of a spontaneous form of
authoritarianism that is kind of emerges
in a sort of not disorganized but to
peer to peer way it's not an official
institution that marches in and takes
over the university but it might be a
network that self organizes and is able
to exert power that way over who gets
invited in over the content of the
curriculum etc and then can essentially
Lobby and pressure and coerce the
university into doing its bidding so
what you then actually need to do is you
have to deal with this spontaneous
authoritarianism that's taken root and
you have to actually marginalize it and
that's actually gonna create a freer
more liberal university so it is
actually about increasingly furthering
the aims of liberalism you're not
actually constricting liberalism through
government action we're not there yet
but I think that is increasingly going
to have to happen because I don't think
that simply setting up an association of
people who support free speech and and
and so on is is going to do it because
when you have the institutions that are
essentially control and not control but
where the red lines of what you're
allowed to talk about and and are
essentially policed by a sort of
self-organizing network um you have to
find a way of actually getting at that
very
small but very influential Network and
to minimize their influence so I think
we're kind of gonna need more
intelligent targeted strategies that are
kind of within institutions and not just
general debates which are important the
culture is still important but it's not
gonna we're not going to get the change
we need and unless we are actually able
to apply more targeted policy tools and
actually on that very subject the
question I was gonna ask you is I was
hopeful or maybe just because it was
Christmas in New Year and I think it's a
new year maybe things will change in
fact that now that you know Boris
Johnson government has an incredibly
strong mandate from the public large
majority for a for a party that's been
in power for nine years in our 10 years
almost is there any evidence that you
know the overwhelming victory of of his
party and the platform that he's stood
on is going to get people to go okay
well you know like with brexit most
people now accept the brakes is going to
happen right right is there a sense in
which elections like that election of
results like that will actually
potentially reduce polarization as
people are given a kind of wake-up call
that going so far off the deep end isn't
gonna work is there any evidence for
that because I was kind of hopeful that
might happen I mean I don't think it's
leading to any rethink on the other side
really and I really don't think it has I
think that and certainly not I mean if
you take the intellectual heart of you
know the cultural left which is in the
culturing industries including
university there's not going to be much
but you know that election is not going
to change many minds now there are
really well there are certainly a lot of
center-left people in academia who
didn't like corbin and they of course
are saying well look you know we've been
vindicated and they're right that but so
they might say well what we need to do
is move in a Blair right direction some
might say that but of course they're
also a lot of Corbin you can't invade
Iraq every 10 years Mike no no
[Laughter]
no I think however what might be an
opportunity is that there are figures in
the government you know Neera mirza
might be one yes of trigonometry
absolutely who do get this issue they
get the importance of kind of having a
readjustment in the culture right and
and sort of reigning in this this excess
that's been going on the problem in a
way is that the senior I think there's a
generational divide so that the senior
Tory people in the Conservative
government are still in the old kind of
thatch right mold and they're still
mainly concerned about things like
brexit and and you know economic free
trade and things like that so their
focus is very much still on high
politics and economics it's the younger
people within the party who I think get
the issue much more and you can actually
see that in survey data on if you look
at people under thirty particularly
under twenty five you know political
correctness is a much bigger concern for
them than it is for people who are kind
of over fifty five you know for I mean
yes those the over fifty five s are
against political correctness but they
don't really care that much about it as
an issue it's not a major thing whereas
amongst the younger people who who are
against political correctness it's a
very very it's like one of their most
highest issues I think that kind of
shows you where this culture conflict is
much more salient to the kind of under
thirty population may because they're
online more maybe because they see it
more in in their institutions and I
think the question in this government
will be whether those younger voices
actually are have an influence or not in
in setting policy and it's really
individual some people they really get
the issue and some it just completely
goes over their head they're the only
when they think of universities all they
think about is oh we've got to reduce
the number of people going to university
and it's costing a lot of money I mean
that's that's the extent of their
worldview rather than maybe we can
actually enact some reforms to improve
some of the the quality of some of the
issues that people are concerned about
and Eric only actually in quite a
dangerous
because we've got these two polarized
camps most people are with you know sort
of the Boris Johnson model
anti-peace we've got the left two uh
sort of you know digging down and not
really engaging or listening and
effectively what we've got is an
opposition that are useless and provide
no real opposition and isn't that a
dangerous place to be in politically it
is a dangerous place because what
happens if the Conservatives bungle
things you know they mess up on the NHS
or they aren't you know maybe
economically they're pursuing austerity
or whatever it is you do need to have an
opposition that is able to credibly
threaten them in power so yeah I think
this is another casualty really of
political correctness that if that
hamstrings the labour party it makes
them unelectable for a generation then
some very real policy concerns which
they bring to the table are going to go
on addressed and there's just isn't
going to be the you know the Tories feet
isn't gonna be held to the fire on some
of these these these questions as
effectively so that's again another of
the downstream effects of this quite
pernicious ideology well that's why
people always talk to us about like why
are you constantly going on about what's
wrong with the left is because we like
Francis's old-school lefty I'm very much
in the center we need a strong
opposition that's what we need an
opposition that can challenge this
government and potentially once this
government gets old and tired and
whatever to replace them right and I
don't have a sensible platform which
they offer to the public but it worries
me what you're saying because you know
as I said I was very hopeful that people
might I thought you know hey just 2020
the elections over people might go well
it'll be really interesting to see the
US election this is what I was going to
tell you because what you in is see is
in the Democratic primary that the kind
of woke nurse has got some power it you
know some of these radical view
candidate Congress people and and some
of the candidates Gillibrand for example
in beta or or can some of these people a
lot of them are are you know trotting
out issues like white privilege and
reparations and so on so you can see a
situation if all of these candidates
sign up to reparations for example that
could make the Democrats unelectable hmm
right if they have to tip their hat to
that now they have still got some
moderate candidates Joe Biden and to
some extent sand Bernie Sanders is
welcome so these monies moderate on the
culture issues if and those candidates
are doing well one of the reasons is the
African American vote which is actually
a moderating influence because they're
less politically correct and they're
less likely to go for this new start
with politics
so Biden may get in on the strength of
that vote and and again that gets to a
lot of this survey data showing you know
white liberals are much more likely to
say that the reason blacks can't get
ahead is racism different City you know
it's sort of but but there is still that
old in older Democrats and black
Democrats are still there to kind of
more or less provide a moderating force
and and so it may be that Biden squeaks
through and as the nominee has the
nominee in which case I think he's got a
very good chance of beating Trump but if
let's say they they you know if it's
Elizabeth Warren or if it were to be one
of these other candidates again because
of that politically correct pressure to
be woke that could make the Democrats
unelectable and then you could get again
another you know now that four years of
Trump what does that mean I mean with
all kinds of you know attendant risks of
what's going to happen in foreign policy
and you know so all I'm saying is again
it's a version of the same problem where
this and and in the context of all these
left-wing European parties that are
having their worst results you know ever
you know and one major reason for that
is that inability to shift to where the
voters are because of these artificial
barriers laid down by an ideology which
is the same political correct ideology
you talk about I'm curious that you you
make this point that that you think Joe
Biden would have a good chance because I
think inside
platform is suddenly but I've been
watching him I mean I'm not sure he's
still all there right you know that's
the knock against him but no I don't
mean that is another kind thing and the
way you've laughed at it now it makes it
seem real uncut I just I think he's kind
of at that point where he needs to be
with his grandkids you know what I mean
he's pretty much getting to the point
where certainly intellectually he's
dribbling you well and I'm not I don't
have a firm view on on how serious this
is people have said well he's had a
lifelong stutter he's always been a bit
bump of a bumbler in terms of yeah so I
don't know if this is just song you want
a bumbler yeah so maybe his someone
mentioned that you know who regardless
of who wins this election the key person
to look out for is the vice presidents
because they're just like a heart attack
away from yeah yeah so yeah I don't know
maybe it'll be the vice president then
hmm do you think Trump's gonna win I
mean it's a horrible question I mean I
think if Biden gets in ice I think
Biden's got a very good chance to win
there but I think other the other
candidates know I don't think they have
why do you think has a strong chance to
win Derek just because he's he doesn't
trigger the Trump base in the same way
as the other can it when I Sanders and
Biden I'd only trigger the Trump base as
much as the other candidates do who are
more on that woke spectrum right not all
of them Andrew yang but he's not he
doesn't have a chance yeah obviously if
he was the nominee yes but I think he
could beat Trump if he was the nominee
yang might yes
yeah apps because he'd have the
Democrats behind him and he has appeal
amongst Republicans but you know he's
not gonna be the nominee why not he just
said he's nowhere in the polls but I
think with Biden he is more of a kind of
unifier he's seen as more not somebody
who's as hostile doesn't he's not
somebody who's likely to think that you
know all Republican voters are a bunch
of deplorable right so he
he doesn't kind of I don't think he
awakens the kind of hostility that a
Hillary Clinton would or or or or that
an Elizabeth Warren or a beta would you
know I think it's a different type of
beast so I think he actually has that
potential to be I wants a unifier but
more in the Obama mold more somebody who
is going to be less offensive to to that
kind of voter and that's why I think
they would be well advised to to select
them and they may well select him simply
given the dynamics of the different
primaries that you know particularly the
more African American heavy states like
South Carolina are likely to support him
so he's very popular with African
American yeah I mean I think yeah he is
and and with older voters generally so I
think that and this is partly a legacy I
mean he was with Obama but also he's a
long-standing fixture and I think the
African American vote is kind of more
stable in terms of party loyalties and
personal loyalties and so that but we'll
see I mean the race is still got a lot
of people in it and the progressive vote
is sort of scattered amongst a bunch of
candidates so as that consolidates it's
always possible that it could
consolidate massively behind say Warren
or or another candidate
I don't think Budaj age is likely to get
it make make it through even though I
don't mind his policy offer but I think
that the real risk I think for the
Democrats is if Warren if the
progressive votes wings behind Warren
and she gets the nomination I think then
they're in trouble
I would I would then bet on Trump do you
not think her cherokee heritage will I
just you know what just purely as a
comedian I would love for her to get
nominated for Donald Trump to call her
Pocahontas so do you I mean you talk
about Joe Biden as it could not unify
but so right do you think this is kind
of the people who are likely to be
successful now we've had maybe a period
of time where it took someone like Nigel
Faraj to break through on break
it took someone like Donald Trump to
break through in America on some of
these issues but now the people who are
gonna start to be successful are the
kind of people who can do that let's say
you know move left on economics and stay
right on culture and move right on
economics and move right on culture and
stay left on economics like the kind of
people who can come to the middle and
bring people in from both sides is that
going to be the type of politician that
is going to be successful going for and
we've we've already seen a lot of that
so the center-right has really done what
you've just talked about Sebastien Kurtz
in Austria mark roots in the Netherlands
even Teresa may I mean you know hi but
she was a great but essentially taking
on brexit taking the mantle of brexit on
from the brexit party or from you kip
making it part of a center-right offer
so the sound of right has been quite
successful in absorbing the energies of
the populace right now the question of
how you overcome polarization is a
different one right so that this is more
the center right and moving in to the
center of where the votes are by
adopting parts of the populist right
platform and not the sort of other parts
of it but in order to overcome
polarization I think again we get to
this problem of the stickiness of the
cultural left which is related to
political correctness which is
preventing the left-wing parties from
moving to the center because if they
move to the center and the right moves
to the center we're then moving into a
more unified situation right and and and
the politics of the center and of the
swing voter becomes much more possible
rather than the politics of appealing to
the fringes in the base or the activists
but the part there are two problems here
one is and and I mentioned this in the
book is this backdrop of demographic
shifting which i think is very important
you know the US case you know roughly 80
85 % non-hispanic white in 1960 and it's
now about 60% and it's going to be below
50% by 2050 let's say that kind of
process is well underway in say Canada
New Zealand Australia it's not taking
place quite as fast in Europe but it but
certainly we're gonna probably see
ethnic majorities in the minority by the
end
this century in the main immigrant
receiving West European country so that
sure we're at the beginning of a process
where these more diverse electorates
what this means is you are starting to
get a kind of response from voters who
say we want this change to occur not as
quickly we want to have time to
assimilate people and probably through
intermarriage in a deep way versus the
people who say no diversity is great and
we want more diversity that is becoming
a fault line and this is this culture in
the the the cultural fault line is
reconfiguring Western politics and
taking over from the economic left right
so this this kind of idea of are you pro
diversity and change or are you in favor
of slower change not as as some some
people would accuse them of no
ethno-nationalism and white exclusion
but simply slower not not zero right so
slower change and less diversity in the
sense that you want time for
assimilation to take place that is kind
of the dividing line but that's a very
hard thing for if you are ideologically
committed if you see if diversity is a
sacred value to you then you can't
compromise on it so sacred values are by
definition values you cannot compromise
on and that means that it's gonna be
really really really hard for the left
to compromise on these issues and move
to the center that then means that
there's going to be this response from
the other side and then especially if
that's a populist response you're then
going to further get entrenchment as
we've seen with this great awoken in
2016 and 2018 in the u.s. survey data
you can see for example the number of
white liberals supporting higher levels
of immigration shooting out like
doubling up to 60% they want more
immigration right okay this is at a time
when border apprehensions have doubled
and there's all kinds of things that use
it so so this question of one side
reacting to the other and the other
reacting to the other is and how you
break that cycle the only way I can see
it being broken is if and I think really
responsibility here has to lie with
those who are pushing political
correctness because that is what is
preventing the system from adjusting
it's like a monkey wrench in the
machinery and it's preventing
people having a rational conversation
about the pace of immigration the the
issue of assimilation and national
identity because that's seen as a a
sacred value you're either for it or
against it it's black and white binary
we can't have the kind of nuanced shades
of grey question about do we want slower
or faster instead of zero or a hundred
you know then that is the way the issue
is framed so I think that until we get
there until we overcome these political
correct barriers to debate we're not
going to be able to compromise on these
questions and they will be cast in very
kind of zero-sum you're a racist or
you're a rootless globalist cosmopolitan
very binary way which is very
unproductive yeah I do like to hear
though that the Latinos are [ __ ]
their way to victory so basically what
you're saying Eric and just to extract
the theme of what you're saying what I'm
talking about is essentially a
left-of-center politician who comes in
and goes we're going to stick with
economic policies right but we're going
to be more sensitive to the fact that
our traditional base working people up
north outside the big metropolitan
cities the university towns what they
want is you know reduced levels of
immigration for a period of time so
people can come they can settle down
they can learn the language they can be
assimilated someone like that according
to what you're saying is in the current
environment could not be successful in
let's say the Labor Party or the
Democratic Party because they would be
called racist as Joe Biden has been
right right that's what you're saying
which is that is the monkey wrench as
you put it that is the constraining fact
in the system that prevents a credible
center alternative to what we now see as
a kind of center-right politics infused
with elements of right-wing populism
yeah exactly and
course immigration is the key issue but
also there are questions around national
identity I mean is the United States
defined by slavery and the sins of
conquering the land from the Native
Americans I mean if you are going to
take that approach to the American past
and reparations and all you so is also
about the question of patriotism of
national idea is Britain just defined by
sins to do with colonialism for example
you know there has to be a leader that
resists that and says yes that is part
of the past but there are all these
great things and this is what I'm going
to talk about is more the great things
you know that would be the kind of
emphasis that you would need to break
through to kind of be that unifying
figure that would that would say you
know of course we're gonna admit the
sins of the past but but that's not what
we're gonna focus on when we get up in
the morning as a country and that's not
what defines us right just that kind of
a tone that would be more unifying and
that would sort of speak to different
groups in the population that would also
accept that not wanting the culture to
shift as quickly as a valid thing
doesn't make you a racist you know
that's sort of a figure you know I try
to imagine that kind of politics
occurring it very difficult right I mean
it's it's very difficult because the
nature of the high culture which through
the universities through influencing
than top levels of the parties and the
activist is very powerful and it is all
essentially about excavating these
grievances and and and focusing on in
justices of the past and essentially
magnifying the meaning of terms such as
racism because that gets you sort of
points as being a virtuous person
somehow we've got to break that in the
high culture move it back towards
something that still calls out real
racism you know we're still gonna be
very we are of course gonna focus on
real instances that are evidence-based
and definitionally tight but we're not
going to just broad brush and and of
course the right does this to to some
extent with anti-semitism you know we're
you know the Labour Party you know there
are anti-semites in the Labor Party and
perhaps at the very top there may be
some anti-semites right but you know to
say that the Labour Party is
anti-semitic I just don't agree with
that sort of framing I think that's
that's not accurate and I think we have
to have tight definitions we have to
have evidence for the claims
we shouldn't over scope these claims or
it just I think just increases
polarization and reduces the quality of
government that we have do you think
what America actually needs weirdly
enough despite his flaws is sort of a
Clinton or Obama like figure someone
who'll come along who'll be more
reasonable it will be more sort of you
know in the center and actually somebody
who can really unifying can talk to both
sides in the way that Clinton and Obama
could well there was an amazing clip of
Obama from I think 2006 or eight or so
he's talking about the the border yes
and someone's literally put a clip of
him next to a clip of Trump and they're
saying the same thing yeah absolutely so
so yeah Obama and Clinton were both in
the center on the issue of immigration
on the border and they were both in
favor of enforcement in favor of
reducing you know illegal immigrants the
number of it people coming across the
border you know they're very sensible on
these issues and they were very much the
unifier I'm not saying that there are
obviously there's some wingnuts who who
claim that Obama wasn't born in the
United States etc so you're always going
to get the nuts but at the same time I
think they were effective and you could
see it in their election you know
victories that a lot of people voted for
them what happens however I would say is
that in the last couple of years of the
Obama administration he sort of succumbs
to pressure from the more the people who
wanted to find want to get out on the
streets of protests when you deport
people and he sort of now you could
argue that it was because the 2014
immigration reform package failed that
the Republicans didn't buy into the the
package of stronger enforcement with
path to citizenship and then he said
okay well if I have got this I'll just
go for I might as well please my base
but regardless it was the base that kind
of pushed the Obama administration in
the direction of blacks border
enforcement and and which which is sort
of the backdrop for the rise of Trump of
course which is post you know mid 2014
with the first big wave of Central
American mothers and children coming to
the border again to expand quite smartly
I would do the same thing as them you
know that they know that the laws are
such that if you come as a mother a
child you can you've got a much better
chance of
of staying in but essentially not
addressing the loopholes intima in the
legislation that allowed that serve as a
kind of magnet for these people to come
in larger and larger numbers it was kind
of a backdrop for allowing Trump then to
exploit that issue so the salience the
importance of the immigration issue for
Republicans was at an unprecedented high
level between mid 2014 and when Trump
was nominated and and it and and also in
the general election you could see a lot
of the non voters or Obama voters who
were concerned about immigration those
were the people that switched to Trump
right so he really drew in people on
that issue but that was only made
possible I would argue in part because
of the pressure from the the you called
them woke activists or people who wanted
to find border enforcement as racism or
as beyond the pale I mean they they
really sort of handcuffed Obama and and
made it you know essentially opened the
field for somebody on the other side who
was willing to break the taboo Cruz
there was a taboo on the Republican side
too and in the right-wing media on Fox
News they didn't want to talk about
immigration as the central thing either
and so Trump had a wide open field 17
candidates he was the only one who was
willing to make this the central feature
of his pitch and so that is you know
this is the key reason why he's in power
so a lot of these things are connected
to again these limits on public
discourse the of Urton window of what's
acceptable to talk about it not to talk
about of course we'd still need the
average 'n window rights how there was a
politician called George Wallace in the
60s who wanted segregation you don't you
know so there of course we need a the
main parties should not go there they
shouldn't touch segregation but
something quite different with an issue
like immigration and enforcement at the
border which is a perfectly reasonable
thing from a liberal point of view to
enforce it's the kind of again the
expansion of the meaning of racism from
something like segregation which
absolutely Falls so very clearly within
the meaning of not treating people
equally on the basis of race to
something like immigration which is
something completely different it has to
do with the relationship of the nation
to
the world outside it which is very
different relationship well as someone
who works with a Venezuelan I have to
say we're out of time and it's been a
brilliant interview as always thank you
so much for coming back on the show make
sure you get white shift Eric's book out
in paperback now it's brilliant I
remember reading it with great interest
and you talk a lot about the demography
side of things which kind of underpins a
lot of the things that we've been
talking about today but last question
always is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society
that we ought to be talking about well I
think what if Trump loses is is one
question I haven't seen written about
much so what if he loses what's going to
happen to polarization on the right
especially you know so I think that I
would like to see someone think about
that question of what is the Republican
opposition gonna be like in a world
where they are out of power especially
if they're out of power multiple
elections for demographic reasons what
does that mean and what does that might
that mean in terms of the risk of
terrorism for example now there may be
no risk of terrorism but I think it's
something that I haven't seen anyone
write about it would be interesting to
see and what do you think would happen
if he was to lose um I think what would
happen is if he was to lose especially
if for demographic reasons the
Republicans and particularly the kind of
border control republicanism that Trump
represents if that were to be sidelined
permanent almost permanently then I
think you've got a more risky situation
I think that what will happen is that
the Senate which is based on territory
and therefore favors more you know the
more white dominated states would become
the kind of center of this kind of
resistance and then the Fox News and the
right-wing media would be kind of taking
it up a notch in terms of attacks I
think it would be a very unhealthy
situation where I think the polarization
would get even worse
a situation where where they are
permanently out of the president's that
is potentially a dangerous one and I
think Yasha monk who's clearly on the
left has said something similar that
it's not enough to attack this this guy
you actually have to have a vision that
is unifying yeah and that's lacking so
we're gonna call this episode no but
you're right I think that's what we need
we need people to start finding a way of
coming together because this is not
sustainable and as you hint at the
consequences of this polarization at
some point potentially could go from
conversations to actual physical
confrontation and that's very dangerous
yeah yeah absolutely and I think that I
mean I don't want to over you know over
draw this I think fear-mongering is not
a good idea either but I think that you
got to play the millinery oh yeah yeah I
never probably move forward but I think
yeah I think that the risk of against
small-scale yeah you know attacks might
go up I mean that seems to be a pattern
we know for example that there's an
inverse relationship between how well
populace right parties do and how many
sort of white nationalist terror attacks
there are this is a kind of inversely
related phenomenon so we might expect
there to be more such attacks when the
when the populist isn't doing as well
which is not by any means a reason for
the populace to be in power okay all
right so thank you very much for
watching make sure you follow Erik get
his book white chips follow him on
twitter @ EP Kaufman at ep ka u FM yeah
they got you peek Ave and as always
follow us at rigor pod we'll see you in
a week with another brilliant episode
take care see you next week guys thanks
for watching guys as always subscribe to
the YouTube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button so you
get notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word